hey everyone i'm lucy today joined by a
very special guest
greg miller from kind of funny hello
lucy how are you
i'm very well thanks how are things in
the living room
why i get all the sun you and you you in
your bedroom you're angled away from
your windows you know what i mean that
was a smart move on your part we should
have probably
i guess a year ago changed up the living
room but we didn't
uh so greg is joining me today for a
very special episode of kind of funny
show
first impressions which you can go watch
youtube.com kind of funny games
but we're talking about the brand new
game from hazelite studios
it takes two which is a cooperative game
where you play
a couple who's getting divorced and
basically due to covid
no one can really do couch co-op with
like we we would an event for the game
no one can really do couch co-op
except for us so benefits of us living
together
one of the many one of the many one of
the many
uh so we're going to talk about our
experience with the game because we
played it for
uh about an hour and a half and had a
really great time with it and here's why
i should be excited
at the very top lucy what do you think
of it i really loved it and i was really
caught off guard by it because obviously
brothers tailor two sons in a way out
uh their previous games from hayes light
are very
brothers is very very emotionally
impactful
and so playing it takes two is
i mean in the presentation like joseph
himself kept saying this is a rom-com
and i was initially a bit uh i had a bit
of trepidation about that
because i've never really seen it work
in a game before but it totally works
and it was really really funny and that
just
and very pixar i think that's the the
big thing is that i was so surprised
with how pixar
is wait what what are you doing we don't
know what's inside there
come on it might be a shortcut to the
house yeah but what if it's not what if
it's
who sent you no one uh
we come in peace we're trying to get to
the house the house
what's your business there we haven't
got time for this
is this a shortcut or not
cody and may the parents here cody the
the the husband
and then yeah may the blue haired wife
here uh
i was playing as cody you were playing
as may and yeah i had
i enjoyed brothers fine i enjoyed a way
out for what it was
and i love the idea that hayes like
keeps trying to focus make these co-op
experiences and try to make these games
that you really don't see a place for
and so from the announcement of a way
from uh
it takes two i was like oh wow that's a
really cool idea it's more co-op it
looks polished i'm excited to see what
it's like it was on my anticipated list
but you know we could have played a
little bit beyond the hour we played
yesterday
and i turned it i was like can we just
stop like i'm in this is one of my most
anticipated games of the year bar none
like i was
not only as your everything i echo
everything you just said in terms of it
looks like pixar
uh in terms of i can't believe how well
acted it is i can't believe
how ingenious it is but even during the
presentation one of the things uh
joseph ferris was talking about was the
idea that they're not reusing mechanics
here like the levels themselves as you
go through there's no
he kept saying there's no [ __ ] to
collect like the levels are meant to be
enjoyed for what they are
and every one of them is incredibly
unique and as we played through it
that's what i was finding time and time
again all these intricate little details
and you know
the when we get going here one of the
things we're doing is you know running
around
uh fighting the vacuum playing with the
vacuum and
just the way that was incorporated of
you know loose you'd have to hold up the
hose i'd have to get sucked in and you
had to aim me to shoot me where i was
going like oh this is brilliant
it's so like creative and what i was
thinking about especially at the
beginning levels it reminded me a lot of
um
the borrowers and arietti and you know
just these
very small characters kind of making the
best of just
stuff that's discarded by the
regular-sized
adults um and so the way as well that i
think is really cool is that they use
these items in the environment so in
this scenario when you're kind of in the
basement
shed place they were talking about the
hoover
and it kind of that's what really ties
it into the fact that this is also a
game about
the dissolution of a relationship like
the parents are getting a divorce
and that's you know kind of the turning
point in the story that
sparks them being shrunk down and turned
into these dolls
and so this hoover becomes this point of
contention where it's like
he was supposed to what was he supposed
to do he was the one who broke he was
yeah he vacuumed up the wrong kind of
stuff he wasn't using it for just dust
he was using like a shop vac
and then she was the one who was
supposed to fix it and so they both
failed in some way on it which obviously
leads to this argument in
doll world that was an argument from
real life yeah it's so cool to watch
how that kind of plays into the gameplay
itself and the fact that
they are being led down this path
through this
book who we'll talk about in a second
but the fact that like
the whole thing is their kid wants them
to stay together and so
all of it requires them to be
cooperating with each other
you know cody will do one thing and male
follow up with another thing
or a path will be blocked off unless one
of them does this the other one goes
over it and it's a really clever
mashup of mechanics and story it's
really
just really well acted and really well
written too
and that's the thing about it yeah you
know when again i was right there with
you and jose was like oh we're making a
rom com and nobody makes rom-coms and
why don't they make rom-co and i was
like
well it's just it's hard to do in a
video game and that was the thing that
immediately caught me off
guard playing it was how well-acted cody
and may were
and the fact that like you know as
they're going through and the k you know
the characters are performing all these
different things like i was engaged in
the way i would be watching a movie or i
would be
watching a cartoon and the writing's so
good and as they start to explain i'm ex
i can't wait to get further into it and
see more of them explore their actual
relationship because obviously right now
it is a surface level thing
you know the game starts with the demo
we got but i'm assuming saw the game too
right of like
you know them sitting rows down and be
like we're gonna you know get a divorce
and then rose
you know walks away not talking to them
but then goes to her dolls
cries on top of them and then you know
throughout this demo it's explained to
us that oh it's a magic spell she
is dropped in real quick of like cody's
like oh we learned about spells like
this is a spell she's put us under
and so that's where it is in the series
here's dr hakeem right now who's
this over the top book of love he's
very much uh has the same vibe as
uh puss in boots from uh
from shrek just the way that he comes in
and he's like
kind of plays into the hispanic
stereotypes a little bit though
i think actually wait is he hispanic dr
hakeem i don't know what he is
he's got he's he's the book of love so i
i that's what i i took away from a
little bit of that the accent he's
putting on
yeah but he kind of says like olay and
stuff doesn't he yeah
so i'm not sure where he we're not sure
the ethnic influence of this book
but he has the same kind of vibe where
he just like comes out of nowhere he has
this
musical interlude and he just kind of
takes over and they play like the guitar
yeah and so he's
honestly like just such a wild little
character that comes in and he
the way that he discusses kind of
through chapters through his own book
it's like cooperation and pulls out a
page and the way that he tries to kind
of
lead them down a path but at the same
time they have a destination that
they're trying to get to which is back
to rose and he just refuses to
immediately take them that he's taken
them
on this journey and they're kind of
going to be damned
if they don't follow him along because
they're kind of stuck yeah he's you know
he's
obviously there to help them reignite
their love or figure out what went on
with their relationship but yeah his
goal
is to get them back together for rose so
like every time you know
rose is within arm's reach of the dolls
right he'll
he'll slam the door he'll pop up with
his musical interlude and then disappear
as quickly as
he appeared to make sure they have to
keep working together as you go through
it and i thought that was another thing
too you know
in the presentation for us uh that isn't
posted uh
joseph was talking about the fact of
like you know you shouldn't play this
per you don't play this with random
people online don't do that you need to
be able to talk he's like you can't just
ping something and understand what to do
and that was the i you hear that in a
cooperative video game like sure okay
but then you know jump cuts at you and
me doing it and where we're doing the
countdown right
of like alright three two one and then
like having to hit the button or timeout
you know as we slide down there's a lot
of ratchet rail sliding going on in one
of the sections that's coming up here in
the vacuum and
having to time everything correctly you
see really quickly where
it is about cooperation even in the real
world yeah totally and
it's like when you're doing stuff
because also you don't
get really uh you don't have a really
bad penalty for dying either because
you're this kind of make-believe doll so
if one of you
falls off the edge which i did a lot
because and that's another thing
the game feel is really really nice you
kind of have this
your light enough but you also have
enough of a weight
so that as you're kind of jumping and
dashing around all the levels and stuff
you feel
it feels really good but it also means
that i was just
i just kept undershooting on all my
jumps and kept dying but there was so
there was you'd kind of reappear
straight away you might have to be a
little bit further back and the other
person would have to wait for you
but it just felt like you're not
necessarily going to be penalized if
you're not
really a game player like you can take
this and you could give it to someone
who's not
a game player 100 yeah and i think
that's because it's got those
traditional controls and like
i wasn't expecting it to feel so much
like mario when we started up right like
not knowing what you're getting into
and just having seen a little bit about
it okay it's a co-op platform or
whatever but you get in there and
it did feel tight it did feel like i was
we were in control and we knew what we
needed to do and i think there are
enough forgiving mechanics like you're
talking about
that you know are designed so that it is
pick up and play and whoever wants to
get in there like
i think of you know they have the the
mario wall jump coming up or
we already saw maybe the introduction of
it and one of the things they're just
like you know the ability to stick to
the wall if you don't hit anything to
give you time to think about what you're
going to do in the next puzzle or how
you're going to address it
i think really helps it's funny you
mentioned mario because they
that's the thing that i was noticing is
that they do the the mario kind of
mechanic introduction
where they give you a new mechanic um so
for example the hammer and nail thing
and they introduce it to you very very
slowly you get to grips with it and then
they just increase that
challenge until the end it's this great
connection where you know you have to be
in sync with the other person
you're doing timings and then you nail
something oh that was
right undeliberate but like you nail
the the two of you working together and
it's just it's again it's story meets
game play in this really great loop
and honestly like doing that boss fight
with the
um what'd you call it the the toolbox
toolbox yeah
and it's just kind of both coming to the
same conclusion at the same time but
what you have to do and then you know
halfway through you just automatically
going where you need to go working
together and it's it's just really cool
so you're fighting this toolbox right
and
you know a whole again it's working
together if you notice right now cody
there who just died and there's this
cool mechanic of you're going to respond
no matter what but if you tap y you can
come back quicker
cody has three nails on his back uh may
their lucy's character has the hammer
head on her back and it was about
working together right so i can
as cody i can throw the nails and then
recall them like thor's hammer but i can
also use them then to
implant on things or as we will do here
in a second as we already
learned as we're about to beat the boss
uh run over here jump on that
then loose that's a hammer it i come up
here and i start throwing the nails to
work on this
paint can to blow that up and yeah
that's what i think
is where this game excels is the fact
that it does work there you know
we definitely got to points where we
couldn't progress without each other and
that's how it should be right in a
cooperative game
like we actually need to rely and we
need to communicate on each with each
other
i think because of the um the easy and
quick respawns as well you're not you're
never getting angry at the other person
you just both kind of go oh
okay i'll see you in a second and that
was the thing too is i wasn't even
getting angry at myself you know what i
mean usually you die you have to restart
something
okay okay let's go and but like even as
we were discovering like this
these nails in the beginning i'm not
sure how close we are to the you know
the very very beginning of this
fight uh were a huge pain for me to
understand because i just could not
dodge them for the life of me and it was
like the hammer the
the shovel kept coming down and hitting
me all those different things but yeah
it wasn't like i was
impeding the group's progress nor did i
feel like i was being we were being
punished because i was struggling to
figure it out
yeah it was honestly and it just felt
really good and this moment in
particular is like really really cool
because you get
like the really good bit of slo-mo and
the fact that you know i'm playing as
maine i knew
i was the one who did the setup and the
new one kind of delivering on it and
it's like
that swaps too it's like cody will
occasionally have moments where he's the
one who's doing the main part of the
puzzle and may is just kind of helping
out in the background and that swaps too
so you kind of equally get
yeah the the glory i guess of solving
puzzles
one of the things in the lead-up to this
fight i really enjoyed
having to work with you with the nails
with your hammer
we're going through and like you know
you're up ahead platforming in front of
me and using the hammer to go around
nails so i have to throw the nails
to time them out to get you there to
then get over there myself to then work
together so you open up
it's like there's all these different
like you you see in your head like
you're talking about it's one of those
like great you know video game serentona
moments we all have of
you know what to do and now it's about
executing on the plan and the game does
such a great job of
giving you these tools giving you light
puzzles you know what i mean
we never stood around going like what do
we have to do here like what's the next
thing to do
you as you said they give you the
mechanic you start to understand it and
then it's like even here we run up to
this for the first time i immediately
see that okay
there's that thing i need to nail as i
die but i need to nail it to the top
right because we know the
the yellow there is something that's a
nailable surface so you need to get in
here and then come over here and then
throw it like that
even though i say it's so easy and i'm
not doing it this was the first time we
did it but you understand what i mean
i get it it's like and that's the thing
and i think the fact that it has that
real world setting you sort of
just it's easy to kind of uh put the
thing
like put the pins together and sure yeah
yeah well
it's got that great stuff of like toy
story and honey i shrunk the kids
together
the hammer's talking to you right now
but when we get everybody out of the
toolbox they dance and they're excited
to be that we saved them right but then
it is all these things that yeah they
exist in a real world like
it's really well done in a way i wasn't
expecting in a way that i can't wait to
play more of
and i love the fact that you're kind of
surrounded by these toy story s
characters like obviously you've got dr
hakeem who is the
who's the through line that kind of
follows you around throughout the whole
thing but
um you also have you know we met the
tools from the toolbox
uh a little bit further forward as well
we met the
the squirrels and the rodents who are at
war with the wasps
which is really cool it's a way and it's
a really cool narrative device
because they're playing not only playing
with sort of genre but they could that's
how you can play with gameplay and so
this is the point where you got a gun
that fires exploding sap and i got as
sort of
i'm not even sure what kind of gun i
have you had a match stick on ya and i
had the thing that could shoot out the
sap right and so yeah you see them
interrogating us here to make sure we're
not part of the wasp army and they bring
in wasp this is another one great one of
them explaining like even to
the creatures in the world that weren't
happening our predicament is weird
because the wasps keep killing us here
and then they're about to be like why
aren't they dying
like why do they keep coming back like
this they're clearly not with the wasp
let's go and figure it out
and so yeah they enlist you with new
weapons and again that's the thing of
you
you know just from the little bit we
played it was like okay cool this is the
vacuum section
this is the toolbox section this is the
squirrel wasp section and so from the
very beginning
here is your tool or mechanic to use in
that area
to then figure out so you know like for
vacuum cleaner it was the figure out the
different suction tubes then you have
one of us shoot each other over
hammer and nail there and then yeah sap
and uh matchstick gun here to go through
the rest of it
i also love the fact that one of the
squirrels was basically sort of
a cue from james bond yeah
exactly exactly yeah they're having fun
with it yeah it's so
it's so fun it's like they have this
little espionage network
and there's a really funny bit where
they talk about all the stuff that's
gone missing from the house
yeah that's just been nicked by these
rodents and
um it's just a really like everything
about it is just so well
thought out and crafted at least from
the the time that we spend with it
hey that's my underwear
you used to love that underwear used to
yeah i don't expect that to go away
right it's such a charming game and it
it's delivering an experience i don't
think we get enough in games and it is
very much polished to be this
narrative adventure for you to go
through and play with somebody and i do
love the fact you know like
again in the presentation and even in
the trailer that they released last week
there was the conversation of like oh
you know and then you you know since
there are different things you can swap
together you can
replay it as the other uh character
whether it's cody or uh um
may and it's one of those things like
yeah okay but it's like no i would love
to do that like it is you know your
experience was so different than mine i
have no idea how the hammer feels or
what it was like to go
swing around with them and like i can
totally see where i i want to beat it
with jen but then i probably want to
play with kevin too and try to play the
other one
and also well that's the thing uh joseph
harris was saying that
no collectibles or anything like that
because and he brought up a really great
point which was like it's difficult
enough to get people to finish your game
yeah
replayability yeah um and so while
you'll obviously have a different
experience playing as the other
character it's not
going to be a it's a linear story it's
not going to be wildly wildly different
which is what i love in games yeah tell
us your story what is your story let's
see what it is and i think you know like
there's no it's a rom-com but it's such
a serious topic
right where i mean you know have it
based around the fact that
their daughter right rose is crying and
wishes this
into existence like i it's one of those
weird ones that he describes as a romcom
but i still don't know if the
happily ever after happy ending is them
getting back together or if it's just
that they can coexist because that seems
to be their struggle right now and
that's
interesting that's a nice narrative
designed to have is coming in of i want
to i want to see
what the other environments and biomes
are going to be for sure and what the
other tools will be but i also want to
know
hey how's this going to shake out for
the characters yeah because i think
that you know we talked about how great
the writing is but also
they do a really great job of having a
sense of these characters have lived
together
and loved each other for so long but
they're at that breaking point in their
relationship and so
there are occasional moments where i
think cody at one point refers to me as
babe
or love or something and it's just
probably like it's an old reflex
but it's after they've done something
and they've worked together on it and so
i am genuinely invested in seeing if
they will stay together or
you know keep going on with that divorce
but it's it's a testament to how well
that's written because a lot of the
times in games
it's you know story in the backseat yeah
that that connection's not necessarily
there but
with these two and like i've said
there's a million times but like how
well the gameplay
links with that story it's it's just so
clever yeah i think that's what's uh
caught me off guard is that i think so
far everything we've seen
whether it be gameplay performance
writing narrative it's all top notch
like
it's i think so far far and away the
best thing hazel
hayes light is done and that's saying
something because they've made great
games
but yeah this one i can't wait to see
all the way through and play a couple
times
this was fun i really love talking about
games with you uh thank you so much for
asking me to be on first impressions and
allowing us to house it on gamespot
nice little collab a little collab on
the internet that's what we do don't
worry about it thanks for having me
thanks for always paying your rent on
time
you're very welcome um what's very
important to me i am building a credit
score
uh greg why can people find you oh you
find all of our stuff over on
youtube.com
kindafunnygames daily content over there
come hang out and talk games with us
hell yeah uh and i'm on twitter at least
james games and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so